hello everybody how you doing this
mapping code techni toriel's what I'm
gonna show you today has to do with a
little bit of magic I've played this
game since I was about 11 I think and
I've always loved it
it's freaking so much fun learned so
much from it said etc Yatta Yatta what I
want to show you though is how to tune
your decks solo play test them solo can
go get a friend together you can do it
online all that but you just got
yourself me myself and I and you want to
play tests and decks and improve them
here's the way you can do it tokens dice
set all this off to the side before when
we need to I'm slightly in view okay so
what you do is you take two decks I've
got two decks here this one these are
commander decks so this is specific to
the commander 1v1 format it would be a
real pain to do a group game like this
so stick to 1v1 there we go
so this deck is playing rolls apex
hydrate as their commander and we've got
all the cards we're just gonna give them
a shuffle there are some expensive cars
in here I haven't got this sleep yet but
my rolls deck here is relatively new so
that is why I want to play text it and
tune it I want to set it over here so
that's its deck now the concept and
there's his commander zone okay so
before I talk about this next deck and
talk about the concept concept here is
you play the decks against each other
and you pretend as much as you possibly
can that they're different people so no
knowledge of the other person's hand
unless you've seen it somehow in that
sort of thing that's very important
otherwise you're gonna get skewed
results pretend you don't know the other
person's cards unless they've shown it
to you
so their deck is soul can are the swamp
king focusing
old-school card very shiny I don't know
if you can see how cool it is but this
is a diamond deck it's three colored not
gonna go over the rules of commander if
you want to look up the rules of
commander go ahead and look them up and
I've got some double-sided cards that
are in the deck the deck off to the side
just in case I draw them so this is a
diamond deck this deck has been a lot of
fun to play I don't see many demons
there but not a demon but Hopi thorax
I got master of cruelties well you'll
see the rest this is basically a demon
deck so demon verse rolls soul can order
the swamp king there's ropes and we're
just gonna shuffle them up this is
probably gonna be a pretty long video I
don't know if we're like fast-forward or
edit much but basically I'm gonna play
these decks out against each other and
talk about some of the techniques you
can do to update them as I go cuz there
are certain things you can do I mean
when you're playing against your friend
or some other player you're kind of you
know you just have to play out the game
or concede or whatever but when you're
playing like this and it's just you
there's some tricks you can do to sort
of head--it your deck on the fly just
you know if your whole interest is
improving your deck testing out cards
you you can kind of deck change on the
fly I can you draw a card and it's just
complete complete garbage and every time
you draw it's complete garbage
you can hot swap it out for something
else in this mode be like didn't know
that your deck is better you're
improving your deck
this is playtesting decks against you
each other your own decks in theory in
the interest of upgrading them and
making them better well let's see you
guys first wanna do some 12 ciders rolls
gets a that's 11 and this guy gets a 11
whoa when you want to that let's try
again 3 into 10 so Rose goes first
all right now my camera stand is in a
weird spot so I'm not I guess I'm just
gonna deal with it you're gonna see my
arm reach across like this every time I
draw beer doesn't it tentacle all right
all right one two three four five six
seven so you generally want to follow
the rules there's that guy's hand and
here's the king hand it's old canard
smoking and drew exactly seven I don't
know if you can see all easily
who else goes first and 1v1 commander
format you started 30 life don't draw a
card if you go first
so he's been played worst pass turn the
king deck is gonna play well not that no
will play the dismal backwater and gain
alight so he's at 31 gain a life now one
of the interests one of your big
interests here is speed you don't want
to be playing against yourself forever
you know us spend all day so you can
take some shortcuts to speed up the
turns a little bit just as long as
you're not wrecking anything
this needs to basic lands too so I'm
gonna be playing some leaves first and I
got enough for ingress rampage but no
point casting that as it is has no
proper targets well that's a proper
target just so I'm gonna do anything you
know what I mean okay
so there we go um let's see rolls Kevin
kind of a weak start now this makes me
consider do I have some things in here
that aren't good like this regrowth the
games you life sure to be in here or
should it be a something else see this
get you thinking about the cards when
you can't do anything and you're just a
deadlock lay your cards or any of them
generally not that great that you much
rather have someone else in the deck
you keep noticing those trends when you
keep playing against your home deck you
should edit them out like I'm sort of
thinking here I see biomass mutation a
lot and it's very situational would I
rather this deck just have a
a three mana or two men on a ramp card
because I am sort of short on those so
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna say all
right in the interest of upgrading my
deck here I'm going to go ahead and do
that this is gonna be a long form video
don't cry
as you know commander is a single zone
format so you can only have one of each
card I already have a spring room Lynn
drew it in this day I already have civic
wayfinder but do I have any other ramp
cards that should be in here that aren't
lana work now we're trying probably not
revive probably not I already have a
seek their horizon over the fence I
don't have a rampant growth so we could
just toss a rampant growth in here it
might be the plate I don't think I have
this guy either when she's not that good
right now but I feel like a graphic
growth should definitely be in the stack
either that or far seek so maybe even
fin torn out her okay I think 4c is the
one so we'll say we're gonna turn that
biomass mutation into a far seek and
that's a permanent deck edit because now
the card in that spot hey we're
upgrading our decks so we're gonna cast
it this I don't know if you hate this
okay I know whatever but this is my way
of doing it this is how I do it it's not
like it matters because when you're
doing this it's just you and one's gonna
get mad that you're swapping cards
unless you're getting mad at yourself
which is just weird and if you want to
just wait till after the game you can -
you can do every one of course obviously
right so you got a card fills the stacks
improved
good ass turn over here things are going
slowly over here don't really know
anything to cast kind of a force of
despair so we're gonna wait we can see
that but kills everything that came into
play this turn so if someone makes a big
drop you can force a despair I think
this card might be a little underrated
especially since you can still use it
when you're tapped out by it's a force
ability thing all right so it's passing
turn can't do anything with this three
mana back over here plays up frost
whatever it's got five minute good cast
the creature could cast Romanus Ronis
whatever how much point though could
cast his of the boss how much point that
you kind of want another creature ending
give the most value so I think if I was
this guy and doing my thing I would just
go ahead and grab two more lands with
circuitous route have you sit up so
we've got one of these already let's
just stick to the trend Forest Island
give it a shuffle I kind of shuffled too
much and he's done so back over here
they are sunken Hall done no longer
comes in tapped rocked afford mana well
not a whole lot we can do for mana
that's value here actually having a
pretty bad start over on this side so
we'll go back we'll pass turn so that
makes me think do I need to edit
something here I've got or is it just
luck I mean you don't want to over
headache sometimes it's just a lot good
if you notice a trend every time you get
card you either don't play it or when
you do it's like waste probably needs to
be yeah that's my opinion so yeah back
over here we drew new yelling getting
some yang Ling she's really strong
concrete eight elementals or her bomb
ability is just so good if you can get
that your Island tap an island drop
guard and boom
that's beautiful so she's like a $10
card I'm a little nervous to have her
sleeve or whatever she's gonna be my
play copy in any case so no I get others
I'll keep them in perfect shape
so I'm debating I got seven man over
here I could play anything I could play
even
I think the cruelest thing I could do is
agent of treachery his target permanent
so I could steal a land and I think I
might just do that if I were this guy it
would either be the Sphinx or steel and
I like to steal land cuz he's not
playing anything I know he's low on mana
and I'll just set him back a turn doing
this so I think I would do that and I'll
take Oh we'll take the sunken hollow so
that is now under my control and pastern
well what'd this guy have a response is
the question and I don't think he would
I'm actually what she can do I mean hmm
everything all the responses are weak I
honestly think if I were this guy in
this situation I would use stroke
Virginia's for one in response there's
nothing else you're gonna do at that
card this game you're gonna die on your
hand all right no yeah
Lotus field I could play it but I'm not
gonna get man out of it this turn so I
think what we're gonna do here we don't
really have any good options to be
honest well anyone can really even play
is forced to despair but I want to get
my Lotus filled out so I think I'll just
go ahead and plague engineer humans cuz
that rolls cos a human and they you know
scratch freezing human so might as well
and then we'll play our lows field sack
these
two lands and Flay over here on this
diamond deck it's it's awkward probably
not gonna turn out well actually in my
previous play testing rules even not a
very good deck an initial build of it
slightly out of did pretty well stomps
the demons most of the time just cuz the
demons are run out of steam
well I'm just getting a LAN screwed this
time to be honest alright it's passing
now I've caught up a situation where I
basically have to regrows in the end
regrowth mother regrowth so I could get
back all my mana and just blow up and
man over here which I kind of like the
idea of but I also want to put the
pressure on is what I would be thinking
too so maybe I can do a mix of both
maybe I'll go ahead and see you once
mana don't have or a total of eight so
this is three we could pulse them more
ah so with three or regrowth with a six
I think well you know we want to get
this Sphinx out so let's go ahead and
just do that tap all eight play the
Sphinx player II grew up on circuitous
route and that'll be this guy's turn so
back over here to the demons it's not
drawing what he needs at all I'm a
really rough game siren sanity pretty
useless demolish pretty useless master
cruelties pretty weak don't have the man
that forced a despair you know what hold
on let's back it up seeing that might
give a C&C money this guy's going to
take the situation if I were this guy
honestly I would force and despair that
Mageau see and to do that
he would have to exile card I think the
one to do is the sire insanity here so
that would be at the end of rolls turn
now his turn all that looking pretty
weak swing with this to to wager
Treasuries only one one so that would
take this guy down to twenty eight
thirty life which is the one to be one
commander I think that's right so there
his life 2008 and there's not much to do
here I mean I could grant page his his
little guy but he's not that threatening
anymore
so I think to play here is just to get
the burnished heart out and hopefully
have a man of a second next turn not
really any other place all right so that
would be his turn back over here drew a
forest play that forest with an island
alright so we've gotten 9 mana can use
c4 and a five or let's see a four and a
five will do that the player rolls with
five of it and will play sir circuitous
route with the other four and get her to
lands of course with two tokens from
rules go over the agent of treachery and
he's a human so he shrank down a little
bit to two it three four two lands will
get island and we first considering
getting the whole islands from this
point out just because of the potential
of MU he angling the sky dancer and
getting her alt going
but I think we'll keep it even for now
because it seems like an okay choice
okay so this guy would go ahead and
swing I think since now this is a 3/4
see it was it one two yeah three four
it's not gonna block the heart see once
it lands so that would cause this deck
to take three damage so at 28 you see
these yeah okay so now it's going just
passing the demons demons Conn land
that's not land but it is more
destruction planeswalker or creature as
a sorcery this one similar but its sack
so we've got a lot of removal here but
the thing is if I make him sack he's
just gonna sack the Treasury I killed
him
rolls he's gonna get double true look
for eight not a lot of good options
there I think we're going to hold and
just sit on our burnished art now
knowing that we're gonna get our to tap
lands because that's really the only
option we have here to be honest on the
demon side if you want any chance of
winning this game tight spot not looking
good over here not drawing the lands
hold and removable and get lands all
right so back over here drew a trigon
predator really good card and we've got
nine mana still so I think we're just
gonna go a little little nutty on this
other player and do with that ball nine
or might not use it all say God eternal
sitting on four mana what are we gonna
do with that last four well we only got
three casts oh well I'm sorry we have
ten minute olds well there's five of it
so one of the shortcuts I like to take
when I'm doing this is rather than being
all precarious and careful about tapping
the right lands is just to count the
toll and if there's sufficient with the
color you just say look ten mana
ten we cast ten man over things and it
saves you a lot of time so I don't know
which one's the best to get out here and
this is kind of a tough choice I could
pulse back the Sphinx of magazi over
here that might be pretty good you do
another big creature up there God
eternal of course doubles these guys
power yeah I'm gonna pulse well given
that I want to keep him pretty well shut
down I'm gonna play no length mule
handling I'll just do that that leaves
only two mana open that's what the see I
would save I don't know that save these
two no these two doesn't matter that
much all right
anything else ten so attack with these
guys they have vigilance because of the
God eternal row Hannes and yeah we just
swing swing block the agent of treachery
here of course and sack it so yeah that
would block that will you stop some
damage snacks it gets you gets what he
needs
so we'll get a swamp and we'll get a I
guess a mountain that helps wouldn't
just manage to top deck lands ooh that
would be really good so tend we offer
cut and it cuts it the role lesk gets by
with an eight damage for uh I'm sorry
six damage it's got a negative one from
the engineer so puts this guy down to 22
alright then it passes turn to the
demons oh wait not yet I forgot all
about the plains water planeswalker here
comes in two counters we're gonna
negative down the plague engineer with
his first ability to get two more
loyalty councilors and then we're fast
to turn to the demons demons top decks a
similar is command which is actually
quite good at this point
almost a two for one here but negative
three negative three isn't quite enough
to kill anything over here but we could
give her that planeswalker could also
get rid of planeswalker with the sack
planeswalker which i think is the right
choice here if we do that so for mana
alright let's do it
sack of lanes Walker gotta get rid of
that anyway one before she becomes a
real problem probably a good choice and
then
and of course we're unaware of the other
person's hand so we have to pretend like
we don't know about this or the Trigon
just block that out he's got two cards
in the ends that's all we know so we got
four mana left we could play well these
guys are out cruelty and singulars
command swamp King can't quite get him
out yet till he usually like to get
swamp King out first we'll light game
but this game it just hasn't happened
no I don't know what to do this is
actually pretty tough I feel like I want
to kill something the agent of treachery
is sort of a problem because well it's
just nothing good to kill here really I
guess we're going to ruin his path the
well if I do rolls kill just play him
and get more counters so I guess the god
of ternal just by a couple turns here
and he's gonna put him third from the
top because that's what happens this
card OOP someone's supposed to look at
this don't cheat
all right so he's done after that it's
past turn and he drew a horizon chimera
okay card alright so I think we're gonna
start over here with the old
I can see one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven minute
eleven minute so we use three of it down
the left cast polska murasa and also
gains us six life just drop another six
over here didn't get anything back
anything at all and we still denying
mana I think we're gonna get the Sphinx
of magazi
and play it just try to end out this
game so we got three mana left will play
a Trigon predator so there's our eleven
man as I count that right one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven okay six three no long enough
we'll have two men left so it's on do a
thing one will sit on those open all
right and then we're going to all-out
attack yet again with rules and agent of
treachery I think this guy has to take
it I mean can't really lose the negative
on the humans so he's gonna take three
four five six damage just takes him down
to sixteen all right
not looking so good over here but it's
his turn so maybe you can happen we drew
a dark steel plate and all that useful
at this stage in the game or kind of in
bigger trouble
ah there are no good options for us to
be honest at this point it is a really
rough I guess we play the soul Kenard
and we sit on our one man past turn this
guy with his eleven mana got plenty of
stuff to do
I've got Flyers I can just go right on
through so I think I'll do that
swing the Flyers six nine four total
nine and we really have no choice over
on the new side but safe to take that so
he's down to seven so I'm thinking
should I be hot swapping these like some
of these cards are just not coming in
handy at all so I could potentially
upgrade this decks power
a hot swapping some of the more useless
things I know this is really hard
choices to make you know generally you
want to like dark steel plate I've seen
it pretty much win games yeah but in my
scenario right now it's not good so I
think I want to keep this cuz it's kind
of almost a theme of the deck you get an
indestructible soul canard he's just out
all game doing work but I could
potentially get rid of Master of Cruelty
is he's kind of cool too though I just
want to keep it want to keep it
demolished could probably go for
something better
Turner scoring I kind of want to keep so
I think demolish would be the one the
hot swap out of anything I already do
have another pillage in this deck so
there's a couple other land destruction
options but I don't know I'm gonna wait
on that
maybe there's a cheaper option just the
Landy is not very good against trolls
but it can be really good for taking out
problematic lands and Commander games
that's why it's in there well this guy
yeah so anyway back to the game rules
take his turn when we go
still got the 11 man I got up to 11 so
tap at all we're not gonna actually
tapping all that will play Civic
wayfinder one two three get a land I'm
gonna get it off the bottom I'm gonna
play it
- shuttles it's kind of off the bottom
so don't feel like it it's yet something
else you can't get away with but also he
might argue that it changes the
randomness of your deck it's one card in
like an ad card deck I don't care right
now alright I don't want to shuffle he's
not this multi deck so that's you know
not too concerned played to trigon
predator because why not and I'll save
the rest of my mana potentially flash
and
Rison chimera so that's what this guy
would do and then he'd be done
Oh for your druid not a human okay here
we go so potentially this guy's last
turn plays in blood fell caves comes to
play tap gives my life well what are we
gonna do I think I think the thing to do
here is some guards command to- down the
trigon predator and i don't know
we're dead and you're bounce sphinx yeah
so we'll do that we could do it at
instant speed in his turn or something
but what if he tries to buck well I
guess we could do in response to the
buff so yeah well hold it and we'll hold
our creatures let him go Oh at the end
attorneys gonna flash from this guy and
drawcard get away from the horizon
chimera and of course god turtles back
and perfect timing to just absolutely
slam the field doubles all's creatures
power and of course you can't counter it
with sim guards command because it is
counter target non creature spell so
that's rough but he's gonna go ahead and
use it anyway negative three negative
three down the trigon bounce mageot see
I'm sure he'll just play again after
combat but let's figure out this combat
six trample in the air eight shrimp well
wait six trample in the air
six trample in the air don't even have
any hair blockers over here that's
enough to kill me so game goes to rolls
and what a play test what a play test
what should i swap is there a better car
than this I know this isn't a very good
card there's probably something that has
more options so that's the kind of
things you can check out and just coming
on the plate a plan didn't exactly help
there's a better land I could put in
here this is the kind of information you
can get playing Dex against each other
there you go that's the video just
that's do it any questions drop them
below and yeah careful not to spend your
whole day playing magic against yourself
I usually take my lands and my spells
more spells lands on that you give them
a good shuffle that way they're not off
this is a land clump right here
so they clumped as I get back just a
quick thing you can do when you're
cleaning up to not have those giant
clumps it's just an initial shuffling so
comes it thanks for watching this video
my little to Commander Dex haven't had
each other and see in the next one don't
forget to Like comment subscribe do
tutorials talks all sorts of stuff so
focused on self-improvement here on this
channel and just really getting good at
technology getting good at coding and
learning how to make logical decisions
in your life is that is that a
contradiction
given that I'm playing magic and against
myself which is like seems like a big
waste of time
not if this gets a lot of use